hello everybody
welcome back to the second session of
every genomics track
on day one of the asia pacific japan
genetic solutions tour for those of you
who joined in our first session
we are talking about the axiom
microarrays
and how they are being used for
various genetic applications
my name is srinivas chadram and i am the
global product manager
for agri-genomics and in continuing our
focus today
on the applied biosystems axiom
microarray platform for
agrigenomic applications we have our
next speaker
dr romel herrera from
philippines he is a scientist
at the philippine karabaw center at the
university of philippines
in laguana and today dr
harara will speak to us about how his
group
has used genomic information to tailor a
breeding program for the carabao
the native buffalo philippines
and how the applied biosystems axiom
platform
was customized for his breeding analysis
for improved milk production
so over to dr herrera
good morning i am romel from the
philippine carabao center and i've been
representing my research in the use of
genomic
information
basically this is a collaboration
between tcc
and the university of new england led by
professor
[Music]
this is really funded by the philippine
council for agriculture
aquatic and natural resources research
of the department of science and
technology
the government through the philippine
cannibal center has undertaken
a genetic improvement program for dairy
buffaloes
selection of dairy buffalo pools is
based on the performance of waters
basically for united states
the philippine carabao center has 12
institutional herds
spread throughout the telegraph this
houses around
1 200 females around 400 are considered
in dams also
we have two cool parts each with the
ceiling processing unit
this house has around 63 holes three
proven booths and around
60 painting pools so in the philippines
we have
two types of water bottle the philippine
swamp
they call it the carabao and nearly used
for
work and then
we have the river type with the
different type of coconut which really
is used for milk
we imported first the american miura
in 1994 and then the bulgarian
around 1995 to 1998 and then the
brazilian
in 2010 lastly the italian mediterranean
in 2013 this
is mostly what we keep in our
institutional heritage
um most of our semen donor moves now are
that we need a new type and we use this
to inseminate
mainly in the process
have better growth and better milk
production
so that means it translates in better
income to the farmers
our breathing structure shown so
as mentioned uh our institutional herds
are spread throughout the philippines
can be divided into hopeless herds and
multiplier herds also shown are the
uh the two blue bars with the same
processing units
so the top pair contains the nucleus
errors these are mainly the nibbling
buckles
the second tier contains the buffaloes
again which are in the multiplier farms
the lower tier contains riverine
cross bread and swamp buffaloes in the
very cooperative teams in
indian farmers
the flow of frozen semen goes from the
nucleus herds
down between the multiplier and very
comfortable
and farmers
in terms of the flow of heifers and bull
genetics
used for natural service comes both from
the nucleus herd and the multiplier
herds
and it goes down to yeah multiplier
hurts and moves
however present country constraints
include the following it's mentioned the
carrying capacity institutional hers is
only
for uh 1 200 degree cows
and we have limited space for protein
investing it only protein tests around
8 minutes per year moreover
accuracies of progeny test moves are low
due to the
small number daughters with lactation
records
and progeny testing is
slow it takes approximately seven
eight years to identify the best use
this very long process is very expensive
okay i now present to the schedule of
protein testing activities
it takes around 100 months
to identify the best best moons
please take note that the water buffalo
was a long registration period
around 10 10 and a half months
and then we could only get semen from
young groups at around
3 years of age 2.6 to 3.3 years of age
it's longer compared to takes time
compared to lady catherine
however with above constraints so
typical for a developing country the
genetic
trend for our population is
going up so on average it
increases 19.5 kilos per year
in terms of genetic trend or milky
fat yield and protein yield it's it's
increasing
so for milk yield it uh increases 8.9
kilograms per year
for fat it's uh 0.89 kilograms
per year and for protein it's 0.37
kilograms per year
not bad now
in 2013 uh the
the buffalo snip chip came out came from
asymmetrics is the first
commercially available is for the
available snip chip
for buffalo contains 123 000
working probes representing 90 000 snips
the total length covered by the snips
where the engine coverage is around
2.658 billion base pairs with an average
inter-proof spacing of 21.6
kb now we use this
in our population so
we try this on
before riverine breeds and from
the philippines one so
[Music]
okay we have three columns representing
the three informative snips the
philippi these are the monomorphic high
resolution slips
the no minor homozygous snaps and the
monomorphic high resolution snips this
can be observed
in terms of deliberate snip riverine
breeds
they have uh more number of polymorphic
snips
on average around 75 percent
compared to the monomorphic snips on
average 7.6
however in the case of the philippine
swamp
most of the snips are of the monomorphic
type
55 000 or 61.2 percent
they have uh lower number of
polymorphic sniffs only 13 129 or
15.5 percent so we
used around only 251 buffaloes
to determine the polymorphic snips
from our local vocal populations
so we generated a pca plot
animals belonging to the different
buffalo populations into the one swamp
population
as can be seen uh there's a clear
separation between the liberian
populations riverine type buffaloes and
the
ernie and the swamp populations
so pc1 is 96.9
so this is swamp buffalo
the blue one is the bulgarian
the red one is the brazilian
and the yellow one is uh the american
to the group together the separate group
is the italian mediterranean
so we did another pca
showing only the four different breeds
so
clearly there's a group formed by this
brazilian hungarian and america
and the italian is separate separate
blue
this can be explained by the histories
of the the breeds
is 75 percent indian era
25 mediterranean the brazilian animals
that we
imported are mainly italian sorry
in general and their process
and the the buffalo from america
came from florida again we checked the
history
it originated from india so basically
this group uh this group of animals the
street needs are
based while the italian mediterranean is
separating the mediterranean
so we also got the pld
for the different breeds so
we got the minimum distance between
markers for
effective coverage for genomic selection
so
bulgarian and the brazilian around 40 kb
in the american around 200 tv so the
average inter market distance is
44 for the bulgarian 43
for the brazilian americans 54.8
so basically i'm saying is the markers
are
dense enough there is a sufficient ld to
do
genomic selection using the
snip chip okay so from that information
a reference population for genomic
selection
contains again this group of animals
brazilian neura american
and their their process
close to brazilian cross to america
because
mostly we have bulgarians even though
the groups
in the reference population since we
have very few people
proven rules we will use all females
and these females will have either one
two or three
adaptation records for animal
now the genomic selection
the reference population on emails but
we will do
single step uh ziploc will include the
pedigree the phenotypes
or the performance data in this case
milk heal
and the genotypes for the reference
population
so we reduce a prediction equation
and then the selection candidates
are males with only the genotypes
because
yeah i will use these
holes a assistant revolution i could
disseminate the genetics faster
to the rest of the population so
election candidates so in the end i will
have selected young wholesale genomic
leading values
hopefully there is increased genetic
gain because
uh the genetic degeneration interval
will be shorted from around
7 to 8 to 3.5 years old
and then since there's no more waiting
bulls or
bodiness testing will be stopped there's
long-term costs
so yeah
population i used 1930 animals
most people here numerous with 3731
records
only 859 genotypes
with 2642 animals in the credible
is the snitch
so this is basically single step
g block so
male 1 selection candidates we use
around only 12
dna tested using this chip
[Music]
so why did we use a single step ziploc
versus the conventional
block model so in single step chip lab
where
he used again the
medical information performance data and
the
genomic information there's the
correction some relationships with
animals in the pedigree
because genomic information is more
accurate
than the family information and then
this links different families
again because we will now use genomic
information between animals
and then this additional snip marker
information provided
by the genotype animals extends all to
the genomic relationships
thus increasing the accuracy of
prediction
we did a threefold validation
were in the
phenotypes considered were animals with
one location or two lactations or three
lactations in the test population
the accuracy we got where the
conventional is around point seventy
but for single step it uh
increased to point thirty so there's an
increase in afternoon thirteen or around
76 percent the reason for this is
the bad reasons correction of the
relationships animals in the pedigree
and then linking the individual families
plus the
extension the
additional sleep information
so this slide presents the scatter plot
of reading values from
single step ziploc
compared to the leading values derived
from the conventional
lab animal model so
the x-axis contains the
edv small t-block the y-axis
contains the reading values per single
step
so the correlation is 0.84
basically there's i'm really interested
in this
anime these are volcanoes
i'm only interested here so there are
there is the ranking animal so 63
percent
are both found in single step block
single step g block and the pedigree
block
another representative representation is
like this so if i would
when you get the top 100 animals from
keyblock the pranking house in team love
in the top 19 house in the single step
62 out of the 100 emails overlapped
basically there's ranking
there's a ranking again because i use
genomic information
together with the pedigree information
so we did a analysis on the
genetic gain and the savings comparing
the
testing versus genomic selection genomic
selection
around 22 to 30 33 increase
in genetically occurs compared to
[Music]
progeny testing it depends on the number
of views in the institution
three to six so that's why this range is
present but still there's an increase in
genetic gain
to use in this election now in terms of
savings
uh due to the reduction of number of
moves maintained from
63 to 40 animals so basically
i don't need the 23 goals there is a
savings of around 121 million pesos
or 28 less
in terms of net present value savings
compared to ep
so we consider the six thousand
ceiling doses per moon five percent
discount rate
15 year time horizon
so if there's a
ranking of females in the
reference population there is also a
ranking of selection candidates
so this uh are the bones
we plan to use in our institutional
herds as you can see this
top three bowls are yeah
are the best ones for the blob
[Music]
but if we did we do the
single step team block the top trainer
would be this bone
this move so
there's a ranking but more less
[Music]
symbols are identified
so these are pictures of our genomically
tested tools
this is lupus donald
trump so these are both bulgarian new
glass corrugated
because of this number first number in
the green
these two numbers will indicate the year
one so these are
2015 born goals
here's dexter so again
they're both bulgarian
he's born in 2015. so
you have two more votes included uh
uh so they're both 2017 born rules
but uh these four goals
are already uh are included in the
mating plan from 2020
the last two moves both born in 2017
will be included later
later this year the meeting plan for the
execution of race
so future plans so we need
really to continue to increase the
reference population
in terms of the number of animals with
performance data
and the number of animals genotype
with limited budget it could only
generate
around two plates years and around 190
animals
per year then
also i need to develop a genomic
prediction model for other traits
since you also collect from this one
field
and somatic cell counts and then
[Music]
the snip chip is a bit expensive so
it's around 200 dollars
genotyping cost including shipping costs
to the united
states so there's a need to develop a
low low density
ship designed for the local population
so lastly i would like to thank uh
university england for
assistance the guidance the support my
professor jesus vandenberg
doctor said of course
all the coordinators the herd managers
and directors of
all the centers i would like to thank
again usc
card for funding this genotyping project
lastly to circa for funding my phd
scholarship
thank you very much for your attention
thank you dr herrera that was a very
interesting presentation
thoroughly loved it glad to see some
work on buffaloes
so the first question i have and i just
want to make sure
are we able to hear you speak
dr harira do we see you
can we hear you
okay so it looks like we may have a
technical difficulty with dr
herrera's line but
here are some questions that have come
up
the first question we have is
what are some specific breeding
challenges that you found
in philippines
so you can type your answer in the chat
the question here was what are some of
the specific challenges that you
found in in philippines
thank you dr herrera for your excellent
uh presentations um
a minor apology to the audience uh dr
herrera is joining us from the
philippines
and he's having difficulty with his
internet connection
we are not able to get him on audio so
what we are going to do uh is to
uh have him respond to
us by chat for the questions that come
from you and then uh
we will repeat those questions uh by
audio either me
or srinivas okay so
yes so i do see the question
yeah so i just the first question was
[Music]
what about future work uh that
you might use the axiom uh platform for
so let's give dr uh romel a couple of
minutes to
respond to that just a minute
so dr uh roman's response to that is uh
he
continues to he plans to continue using
the axiom
platform and he's planning to use the
buffalo snip chip to evaluate
a future to evaluate
future selection candidates
namely semen donor books
okay the next question that has come
is uh dr herrera how about
what are your plans for using a targeted
gps in the future this is not directly
linked to
[Music]
his use of the axiom let's just give him
a couple of ministries
okay subbu can you hear me
christina can you hear or michelle can
you hear
okay thank you uh so i do see a response
from
so his response to that is that he will
mainly use targeted gbs if he chooses
that platform from us to
genotype the heifers and if we can
identify the animals with high breeding
value then he plans to
inseminate them using semen from
their elite sires
the next question is
what is the direction of his uh future
research uh with the act not just with
the action platform but where is his
genotyping work going let's give him a
couple of minutes
okay uh we have a new question here from
the audience
uh the question is how much time
have you saved using snip chip in
selecting your approved
bull
so um i think dr herrera is not able to
get our audio so we will have some of
these questions answered
via email to all of you
we will send these questions to dr
harira
and have the responses sent to you
i think uh there was a response to
regarding the future plan in terms of
low density
of array design how do you pick up
the markers of interest
and so the answer that dr herrera
provided previously was that
they are going to look into the
indigenous populations
and try to use those markers
for the design of low density arrays
okay i guess given the the technical
challenges that we are having
because of the audio issues
we will get back and please do uh
send us your questions we will have our
team respond and
check with dr herrera and get back to
you
and we will try to respond
to all the questions
with that i would like to announce that
tomorrow we have another exciting
session
uh definitely join us to hear about the
applied biosystem agric
targeted gbs applications and how
that platform is used for advancing agri
genomics
we do have exciting speakers
from the region and we
look forward to seeing you in tomorrow's
session
thank you
you